welcome
to earth city yeah you heard that right
you're not going on a globetrotting tour
to see all the planets major cities
you're already there today
the entire planet is just one massive
city
how would we build it how would we get
around
[Music]
and is this a disaster waiting to happen
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if earth was a massive global city
okay so to imagine what our lives would
look like
in a continuous planet-consuming city
we need to set the stage first off
we're going to have to be a type 1
civilization
then collectively we can use all the
energy
available on our planet it also
gets rid of the monotony of having all
the world's leaders
argue over the direction of earth city
we all came together and agreed on the
urban planning
okay yeah i know science fiction
earth city would likely be divided up
into several sectors or
zones each of these would have its
purpose
for example you'd have the financial
districts industrial
senatorial and even entertainment hot
spots
the difference is they're not taking up
a few blocks
they could be taking up the size of a
country okay this is
sounding pretty cool but we have a tough
decision to make
we need to decide if our latest urban
planning project is
going to cover our oceans or not
well here's the thing unless we catch a
break
and become an interplanetary
civilization
we have to make our resources count if
we did
cover all our oceans in our expansive
global city
we would have to have advanced
technology to back us up
if we didn't there would be no
ecosystems
to support the atmosphere and global
temperatures
and we're thinking leave the oceans the
way they are
so knowing we're staying on dry land
what would your new digs look like
[Music]
well you'd likely live in a towering
skyscraper
it's got a heck of a view but here's the
downside
homes with backyards or green spaces
would become a thing of the past that
space
would be used to build more city any
green space
would need to be artificial or indoors
like botanical gardens or museums
ah remember parks has a direct result
we're going to have to get a little
creative with how we farm
without the land needed for agriculture
vertical farming would become necessary
lab grown meat would likely be used to
feed the growing population
right so these are all things to
consider but
i can't help but worry about one thing
my commute to work
if we turned earth into one global city
our
transit system would need to be
spectacular
the hyperloop system would be a series
of tubes
meant for passenger or freight
transportation
because they are virtually free of air
resistance or friction
the hyperloop could travel at hypersonic
speeds
all while being more energy efficient
than our
current train systems this means we
could get to work with enough time to
grab a coffee even when traveling across
the world
so could something like a massive global
city
actually happen well maybe
the united nations says 55 of the
world's population
lives in urban areas this number is
expected to
increase to 68 percent by the year 2050.
that means the city expansion train is
going to keep on chugging
will it go as far as to convert the
whole planet
into one major city probably not
how can i put this humans don't
usually play well with others even if we
had the advanced technology needed
this would all come down to people
cooperating and
uniting religions races governments
cultures and classes so before our
cities can grow we have to do some
growing ourselves
okay now what well all this urban
planning has got me in a building mood
how about we give our city a test run
and
take a crack at building it underwater
what if we lived in cities underwater
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]